mon invité dans cette édition c'est
didier fischer bonsoir maire sans
étiquette de coignières vous serez la
tête de liste d'un élan durable pourquoi
hier on rappelle le contexte vous avez
été élu pour la première fois en
décembre 2018 lors d'une municipale
partielle succédant à jean-pierre
sevestre est démissionnaire après une
période de vive tension dans la commune
la fusion avortée avec maurepas qui a
causé une opposition citoyenne et aussi
des défections au sein de la majorité
municipale elle jean-pierre sevestre
avait lui même succédé à henri pailleux
maire depuis 1986 et qui a démissionné
en avril 2015 voilà pour le contexte le
contexte posé après plus un peu plus
d'un an de mandat il est évident pour
vous de vouloir transformer l'essai de
continuer de continuer cette mandature
avec un mandat plus long oui ce serait
ça semble être une évidence d'autant
plus je pense pas qu'on ait démérité
on avait un projet qui était ambitieux
mais réaliste on l'a réalisé aujourd'hui
à 80% les 20% restants en définitive
sont en cours
donc on est plutôt satisfait de cette
mandature
ça veut dire cette période de tension
clés en 2018 elle est totalement
derrière les coins rien je vais pas
sauter de nos promesses d'ailleurs
c'était de revenir à de la sérénité de
redonner un nouvel élan à la ville et à
l'action municipale
aujourd'hui les poignées rien je
rencontre me disent que c'est gagné
d'une certaine façon c'est à dire qu'ils
sentent effectivement cette sérénité
aujourd'hui retrouver en ville
et puis il ya cet élan il ya ce
dynamisme qu'ils apprécient d'une
manière générale maintenant évidemment
on compte pas forcément tout le monde et
les hommes qui me parle ce n'est
peut-être pas ceux qui sont opposés - et
donc voilà
et si vous faites le bilan vous disait
que 80% du programme 80 % du programme
qui réalisé bon je pense à la maison des
jeunes je pense à la réfection du
city-stade eux je pense au gymnase qui
est en quête en travaux en ce moment il
ya d'autres
d'autres réalisations on a on a mis par
exemple en place un véritable service de
l'insertion professionnelle et puis à
quelque chose dont je suis content et
l'équipe aussi est contente c'est la
fameuse navette scolaire puisque nous on
a une ville quand même avec des
quartiers excentrés l'autre côté de la
nationale 10 et ça c'est très utile
aujourd'hui pour les enfants pour qu'ils
puissent se rendre dans les deux groupes
scolaires et on voit bien c'est une
réussite puisqu'on est parti on avait 22
enfants en septembre aujourd'hui on en a
45 qui sont véhiculés de cette façon là
et c'est c'est intéressant parce que je
m'en étais pas rendu compte forcément
tout de suite mais les parents me disent
ils ont gagné en autonomie
les enfants gagnent en autonomie nous on
a gagné au niveau environnemental aussi
parce qu'on a moins de voitures devant
les écoles et d'une façon générale c'est
un vrai service qui est rendu
aujourd'hui cette catégorie de la
population
or votre liste sera une nouvelle fois
sans étiquette comme il y a un en cdd
fischer vous êtes un homme de gauche est
ce que vous vous revendiquez une
investiture est ce que vous attendez un
soutien on en entend qu'un soutien
revendique aucune investiture la liste
sera sans étiquette moi-même et et mes
colistiers ne sont pas encartés donc
voyez on est vraiment tout à fait libres
indépendants quelque sorte même si
évidemment en tous les cas moi j'ai eu
un passé à gauche et je reste un homme
de gosses bien entendu d'ailleurs ça se
sont aussi dans la botte dans les
politiques que l'on mène je pense à
coignières il ya une attention très
particulière dans le domaine social
notamment
mais au sein de votre liste diverses
opinions politiques est ce que ce soit
justement avec la même équipe que vous
allez proposer cette candidature de la
même équipe vous aviez un renouvellement
effectivement il ya un fort noyau qui
sera effectivement le noyau de base mais
qui est important ils ont l'équipe sera
renouvelée aux environs d'un tiers à peu
près aux environs d'un tiers ce qui
permet d'afficher aussi un certain
renouvellement des visages nouveaux des
gens qui veulent s'engager pour leur
commune qui veulent travailler dans
l'intérêt commun
dans l'intérêt collectif je pense que
c'est une bonne chose et il n'y avait
pas de raison aujourd'hui oui la liste
est complète j'ai même j'ai dirigé des
je suis encore en train de faire un
certain nombre de choix parce que c'est
quand même pas évident et puis j'attends
encore un peu avant de publier cette
liste mais la liste est complète oui
bien sûr votre programme au plus tôt à
vos priorités pour la commune vous les
avez évoqué dans une lettre adressée aux
habitants novembre dernier volet
environnement notamment vous souhaitez
que coignières intègre le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
une intégration qui pourrait être
progressive à partir de 2023 avec un
statut de ville porte pour coignard
pourquoi pourquoi cette démarche
pourquoi vouloir intégrer le pnr je
pense que c'est important pour pour
coignières qui a une image qui n'est pas
forcément une image très bonne du côté
de l'environnement quand on voit cette
nationale 10 quand on voit ces zones
d'activités qui sont aujourd'hui dans
une situation un peu de dégradations
dans certains certains côtés donc l'idée
d'intégrer le parc naturel de la haute
vallée de chevreuse
c'est en fait
une façon de dire vous voyez coignières
c'est aussi un village coignières c'est
aussi 70% des terres agricoles
coignières c'est aussi aujourd'hui parmi
ces terres agricoles 70 % de terres qui
sont en bio donc on serait on serait
sûrement la commune aujourd'hui qui
aurait le plus de terre en bio si on
était intégrée au parc naturel de la
haute vallée de chevreuse et puis
quelque part c'est profiter de
l'ingénierie du parc aussi dans tous nos
comment dire dans toutes nos politiques
ça pourrait faire profiter notamment tu
es des projets en termes de patrimoine
et aussi du patrimoine en vue pas
souhaité faire classer l'église saint
germain d'auxerre voilà c'est
effectivement un de mes souhaits et ça
sera une de mes propositions
le classement où l'inscription je dirais
aux monuments historiques donc de cette
église
tout simplement parce qu'elles le
méritent c'est une église qui est une
base du 12e siècle du 12e au 19e siècle
qui a des superbes vitraux qui un
tableau aussi de valeur à l'intérieur et
cela permet aussi de définir une zone de
protection si pour le vieux coignières
pour l'ancien village donc et ça je
crois les habitants sont très attachés à
la protection de leur village autre
volet c'est la culture vous voulez doter
la commune d'une politique culturelle
importante avec la mise en place d'une
direction dédiée à l'idée c'est de
donner notamment un nouveau souffle au
théâtre alphonse daudet n'y a pas assez
de quoi n'y a rien qui se rendent
aujourd'hui dans ce dessein 20% les
spectacles aujourd'hui au théâtre d'auch
des ces 20 % du panier rien là j'ose et
à 20% je trouve que c'est insuffisant je
rencontre des gens qui me disent
le théâtre c'est pas pour nous eh bien
si c'est pour vous c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui il faut vraiment développer
une politique culturelle d'envergure
parce que la culture c'est pas
simplement ce petit supplément d'âme
c'est la vie et je crois qu'on a tous
besoin en effet de culture alors je veux
aussi par exemple par rapport au théâtre
y créer des activités qui sont pas
forcément des activités théâtrales par
exemple qui a réparé café qui s'est
installée au théâtre ce qui fait qu'il
ya des gens qui viennent pour réparer je
ne sais pas moi un grille pain
un poste de radio et puis qui entrent au
théâtre qui voit les affiches qui voit
les programmes puis qui se disent après
tout tiens pourquoi pas eh ben c'est
gagné et j'ai eu deux trois réflexions
comme cela de la dernière fois lors du
dernier et parcs cafés ou des gens qui
m'ont dit ah bah finalement ça veut pas
bazot prévenir la prochaine
représentation la voyez c'est ça
finalement
c'est comme cela la culture elle infuse
de cette façon là alors d'autres
priorités on aura l'occasion d'en parler
dans différents reportages d'éducation
famille emploi je voulais vous faire
réagir ce que vous êtes également vice
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge de
l'action sociale est ce que le travail
avec la collectivité vous menez ce qu'il
est satisfaisant est ce que vous
souhaitez le renforcer avoir écouté si
on peut le renforcer le renforcera mais
moi j'ai très bonne relation et je
dirais on travaille en confiance avec la
collectivité avec l'agglomération
on travaille aussi sur tout ce qui est
aujourd'hui requalification urbaine
études paris ouest le comment dire le
carrefour de la malle mot donne voilà là
on travaille très bien avec les équipes
avec les équipes de soins de
saint-quentin dirais que c'est déjà
engagées c'est à dire qu'il ya déjà une
relation qui est forte
le passé c'est le passé vous savez
comment la poigne air est entré
finalement dans la communauté
d'agglomération ont ils été précipitée
par un arrêté du préfet bon aujourd'hui
par une décision préfectorale
aujourd'hui c'est le passé aujourd'hui
on est à saint quentin en yvelines
eh bien on va jouer on joue notre rôle
au sein de l'agglomération
dernière chose très rapidement ce
programme vous allez le co construire
avec les habitants vous organisé
d'ailleurs des ateliers thématiques cci
organisé toute une série d'une série
d'ateliers thématiques au jeu rendez
vous avec les lots 16 janvier où on va
faire un rendu justement de ces ateliers
thématiques et on va commencer à
proposer les premiers véritables
éléments du projet merci didier fischer
je rappel merci beaucoup et maire
sortant de coignières tête de liste aux
municipales de cette candidature sans
étiquette un élan durable pourquoi n'y a
et le précise qu'une autre liste est en
course aussi pour le moment dans la
commune celle menée par et xavier girard
qui amènera la candidature citoyenne
coignières à venir